So, hopefully we now are setting
all sorts of error states, but
we aren't using them to help
display anything to the user yet.
Let's change that.
First, we need to add a new utility
method to get the current location
status, and next, we'll update
the function that changes the string
displayed in the empty view to use both
the location status and the network
state, instead of the call we have now,
that only looked at network status.
As I mentioned before, one of the great
advantages of using a shared preference
to store the status of the location,
is that we can listen for
changes to shared preferences.
We'll have forecast fragment implement
an onSharedPreferenceChangeListener.
We'll register this listener with
default SharedPreferences in onResume,
and unregister it in onPause.
When the location status changes, our
onSharedPreferenceChangeListener will
get called, and we can update
the string displayed in the empty view.